ونحييكم الى التفاصيل خلافات بين الدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان تزويدي
اوكرانيا بدبابات مسؤول وسياسه الخارجيه
والامنيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعلن انه لا تزال هناك خلافات بين الدول
الاعضاء وان بحث المساله لا يزال مستمر
ووفقا صحيفه كوتديانو ناديه الايطاليه
ستتمكن الدول الغربيه من امداد اوكرانيا
اقل بكثير مما تطلبه كياس اي يمكن ان
تتلقى اوكرانيا من ثلاثه وثلاثين الى 73
قطعه بحلول الربيع ليصبح المجموع 77 وحده
بحلول بدايه الصيف وهو اقل بكثير من 300
قطعه طلبتها اوكرانيا ويناشد مسؤولون
اوكرانيون منذ اشهر الخلفاء الغربيين
بتزودهم بالدبابات الحديثه المانيه الصنع
ولكن مين حتى الان امتنعت عن ارسالها او
السماح للدول الاخرى بهالشمل الاطلسي
بارسالها
نعم لقد طلب الرئيس الاوكراني بولودي
ميرسي دبابات لكن ارى الدول الاعضاء
مختلفه سنبحث هذا الامر
برلين لن تعرض رغبتك هولندا في ارسي
دبابات اليو بارك المانيه الصنع الى
اوكرانيا لمساعدتها في سد الهجوم الروسي
نعلموكم ان هذه الدبابات مهمه لذلك نبحث
في ذلك الان مع شركائنا
الغربيه
لن يغير مسار الصراع بل انه سيزيد مشكله
الشعب الاوكراني
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من بون عبر
سكايب الدكتور جاسم محمد رئيس المركز
الاوروبي لدراسه مكافحه الارهاب
والاستخبارات ومن كوبنهاجن سامر الياس
الكاتب المتخصص في الشؤون الروسيه اهلا
بكم ضيوفي لمحاوله فهم في الواقع الموقف
الالماني مع تعدد
الاراء وتصريحات سيد سامر وسؤال لحضرتك هل
هذه الازمه او كما اسمائها وصفها البعض
بالازمه هي ازمه دبابات بمعنى انها
تباينات في الاراء بخصوص تقييم هذه
الدبابات او ان الازمه اعمق واكبر وهي
ازمه موقف همم المانيا من امتداد او
امكانيه توسع هذه الحرب
تحيه طيبه لك واهلي المتابعين الكرام
والضيف الكريم ايضا اعتقد بان الازمه هي
اعمق من موضوع دبابات وامداد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات البارد 2 او غيرها ازمه تتعلق
بالموقف الالماني الذي متاخر قليلا عن
المواقف الاوروبيه حيث ان المانيا تريد
المحافظه على موقفها الذي بدا منذ
السبعينات وتعزز في بدايه الالفيه الحاليه
وهو الحوار مع الجانب الروسي والحوار مع
جميع الانظمه الاوتوغرافيه من اجل دفعها
نحو الديمقراطيه ايضا التعاون من اجل
المصالح المشتركه شهدنا ان هناك علاقات
كبيره بين روسيا والمانيا في مجال الطاقه
والكل يعلم بان اوكران بان همم المانيا هي
المستورد الاكبر للغاز الروسي منذ سنوات
طويله وجدنا مشروع نورتستريم واحد ومن ثم
مشروع نور الدين سليم الذي لم يبدا بضغط
الغاز بسبب الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هناك ايضا عامل تاريخي اعتقد في هذا
الموضوع واتعلق بان المانيا تجد بان
مسؤوله عن اي قتل يمكن ان يحدث في روسيا
نظرا لمسؤوليه التاريخيه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بصفه روسيا الوريثه
للاتحاد السوفيتي السابق ولكن هذه النظره
ايضا قاصره لانه هناك الملايين ايضا من
الشعب الاوكراني الذين قتلوا بسبب اله
الحرب النازيه في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اثناء اجتياح الجيش النازي للجانب
الاوكراني اعتقد بان جانب الالماني همم
يريد ان يكون هناك همم اجتماع اولا اوروبي
واجماع من الناس والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومن ثم سوف يسعى الى اقناع
الشعب الالماني الذي بالمناسبه معظم يدعم
الجانب الاوكراني ولكن نصف منقسم في موضوع
تزويد الاسلحه لنتذكر بان المانيا هي ثالث
اكبر داعم في موضوع الاسلحه بالنسبه ليه
اوكرانيا بعد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمملكه المتحده لكن وهي بذلك اسقطت جزء
من التاب او
المحظورات التي فرضتها المانيا بتصدير
الاسلحه الى مناطق الصراع وخاصه لمسؤوله
عنها والتي كان شاركت في المانيا لكن
الموضوع البارد اعتقد بانه موضوع سوف يتم
حسمه في الايام المقبله عند همم يتم اعداد
الجمهور الالماني له تقبل هذه الخطوه
التقارب التاريخي الالمانيه الروسي الذي
قد يؤثر كذلك على مسار هذا التحالف ولكن
دكتور جاسم هل تتفق بان المانيا متردده
المانيا اخره مقارنه ببقيه الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبان هذا قدي ينسحب على بقيه
قراراتها المستقبليه
نعم هنالك اجماع لدى وسائل الاعلام
والمراقبين بان المانيا بالفعل هي متردده
في موضوع الدبابات دبابات ليبردو تو هذه
واحده من اكثر القضايا التي كشفت التردد
الالباني ونجد انه حتى الاجتماع الذي كان
بقياده وزير الدفاع الامريكي في قاعده
راميشتاين قبل يومين كان هنالك اجماع
وكانت هنالك ضغوطات خاصه من اوكرانيا ومن
هولندا وكذلك
بان هذا التردد
يختزل في موضوع الدبابات ام كما يراه في
اعماق
وبانهلامس موقف المانيا همم من هذه الازمه
لا اكيد اتفق مع ضيف الكريم بين يعني
اسباب التردد هي اعمق من الدبابات الي
برضو هذا التردد هو يعود الى ربما كانت
فيها المقدمه انه العلاقات التاريخيه
وكذلك العلاقات الجغرافيه والديموغرافيه
ما بين كل من روسيا
وكذلك المانيا هنالك علاقات تاريخيه
وهنالك ايضا اجليات او ربما المان يسمون
هناك بالاوس سيتلر يعني
المهاجرين الذين اقتربوا عن المانيا
واستقروا في روسيا وهؤلاء يمثلون جاليا
كبيره او ربما شريحه كبيره حيث عاده في
عقد التسعينيات من همم يعني من روسيا
واستقروا في المانيا وحصلوا على الجنسيه
الالمانيه بعد التاكد
السجلاتهم المدنيه بانهم من اجداد او من
اصول المانيه يعني هذه الشريحه ايضا هي
تحظى ايضا بالتاثير او بالاهتمام في
المانيا
تحالف كذلك تحالف اوروبي وهناك اتحاد
اوروبي في اعرض الخطوطه همم تحالفاته
مرسومه للحفاظ على مصالح الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودول الاوروبيه همم استاذ سامر هل تراب
طالما انكما اتفقتم على الاقل بان الموضوع
قد يكون اعمق واخطر على موقف المانيا ولكن
استاذ سمر هل ترى بان هذا الموقف يمكن ان
يغير من مواقف المانيا المستقبليه لن
نتحدث عن لا يباعر يمكن ان يكون هناك وجود
فما يخص هذه الدبابات وقالت المانيا بانها
متردده ولكن الحلول موجوده ولكن المواقف
القادمه اذا ما طال امد هذه الحرب
اعتقد بان الجانب الالماني يدرك بان
اوكرانيا تقود معركه من اجل المحافظه على
استقلال الاتحاد الاوروبي ومنع روسيا من
التقدم اكثر اجانب الاوروبي دفع ثمنا
كبيرا عندما تباطئ في فرد عقوبات قاسيه
على روسيا في عام 2014 عندما غيرت روسيا
الخريطه الجيول السياسيه للقاره الاوروبيه
بضمن شبه جزيره القرن في عام التي كان قد
تعهد الاوروبيون
بانها جزء من اوكرانيا واعترفوا بانها جزء
من اوكرانيا بعد استقلالها عن الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق
الماني اعتقد بانه سوف يخفف كما بدات هذه
البوادر بالامس بتصريحات وزيره الخارجيه
بانها لا تمانا في ان تسلم همم بلدان اخرى
اوكرانيا دبابات ولكن هذه كميات المشكله
انها لا تكفي بشكل اساسي اجانب الاوكراني
طلب اكثر من 300 دبابه واكثر من 600 مدرعه
من اجل القيام بهجوم الربيع اليوم نجد بان
الجانب الروسي قد بدا هجوما في اكثر من
محور وهناك انباء عن قرب اطباق محاصره
مدينه فخمود التي صمدت منذ شهر يوليو تموز
من العام الماضي وهناك انباعا هجوم على
منطقه زاباروجا هذا ينبع الاوروبيين وفي
مقدمتهم المانيا كاكبر قوه اوروبيه امام
تحدي مهمه وهو انه يمكن ان تنكسر اوكرانيا
في هذه الحرب واضح تماما ان المعادله
الالمانيه حتى الان تقتضي بانه منع روسيا
من تحقيق انتصار على اوكرانيا ولكن ايضا
عدم تمكين اوكرانيا من الانصار على روسيا
في هذه الحرب خوفا من التحضيرات التي
اطلقها 100 ريال مدريد الرئيس السابق وفي
الاردن رئيس مجلس النواب وغيره من
المسؤولين الروس عندما ذكروا بان روسيا هي
قوه نوويه وانه لا يمكن هذه القوه النوويه
بمعنى انه يمكن ان نستخدم الاسلحه النوويه
في اي لحظه يمكن ان نجد نفسنا قد اق من
الهزيمه لذلك همم
سامر دكتور جاسم ما
راي لدعمون اوكرانيا ولكن في نفس الوقت
همم والمعادله التي طرحتها يعني ملفته في
الواقعه استاذ سامر بان الالمان في نفس
الوقت لا يودون رؤيه همم اوكرانيا رابحه
في هذه الحرب همم تتفق مع ذلك
وتوافقه على ان المانيا لها حزير كذلك في
هذه النقطه
المانيا هي تعتبر ربما يعني احد ابرز
الدول التي قدمت الكثير من الدعم الى
اوكرانيا داخل نيته فا برغم التزاماتها مع
النيته وكذلك ضغوطات داخل الاداره
الامريكيه على المانيا نجد انه المانيا هي
لا تريد ان تنخرط بشكل مباشر في الحرب معه
اوكرانيا فلذلك ربما كان هنالك تصريحات
همم
الى الرئيس
ربما قبل شهر هو يقول بانه همم لا يريد ان
يرى همم روسيا منتصره فيها الحرب وكانت
انتقاداتك كبيره الى شولز وهذه الانتقادات
تقول لماذا لا يقول شغل انه يجب ان تنتصر
اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب فاذن هذا يكشف انه
مدى بصراحه الموقف الحرج الذي يعيشه همم
يعني المستشار الالماني وكذلك الحكومه
الالمانيه المانيا حتى في قضيه همم
الدبابات هي تجد انه هذا انقراض ربما
مباشر في الحرب مع روسيا وهي لا تريد بشكل
مباشر
لا تريد ان تكون رئيس حرب ايضا في هذه
الحرب
المانيا ان ترى نفسها بصوره المنخر مباشر
في هذه الحرب همم نعلم بانه هناك مخافه
هناك دعوات ولكن الواقع يقول بان الاتحاد
الاوروبي كما تراه روسيا انخرط فعليا في
هذه الحرب وهنا سؤال استاذ سامر همم هناك
في داخل الالماني من يقول بان المخاوف لا
تتعلق فقط حين تحضيرات الروسيه وانما كذلك
تتعلق بمستقبل اوكرانيا اذا ما تسلمت هذا
الكم من الاسلحه همم هناك حتى من يصف
الارض الاوكرانيه بالارض الزلقه همم ولا
نعلم كما يقول نتائج هذا التسليح ما رايك
انا اعتقد بان الجانب الروسي هو الذي طرح
هذا الموضوع طرح بدايه موضوع المرتزقه
الذين يحاربون الى جانب اوكرانيا وفي
المقابل رئيس بوتن دعاء قسم كبير من
المرتزقه من مختلف دول العالم من البلقان
ومن البلدان العربيه للقتال الى جانب
الجيش الروسي ايضا حذر من ان هذه الاسلحه
يمكن ان تذهب الى
القاره الاوروبيه وان تنتشر الجريمه وغير
ذلك هذا كان دعوه ربما من اجل تحفيز
الاحزاب اليمنيه
الروسي الجانب الالماني كذلك هناك همم
جنرال كان في ما قبل المستشار لانجولا
ميركل لا يدعى ريتشارد ان كان نطق صحيح
قال بانه اوقفوا التسليح بهذه الطريقه
المخيفه لاوكرانيا
نعم انا قلت بان الجانب الروسي بدا بهذه
الدعايه ولكن بطبيعه الحال هناك اطراف في
اوروبا داعمه لروسيا هذه الاتراك بشكل
اساسي من الاحزاب اليمنيه المتطرفه التي
دعمتها روسيا لفتره طويله وايضا بقايا
الشيوعيين الذين ما زالوا يدعمون الموقف
الروسي اضافه الى وجود فريق كبير في
المانيا من دعاه السلام وهذا لا يقتصر على
احزاب الاشتراك وغيره ولكن في جميع
الاحزاب الالمانيه هناك فريق يريد
المحافظه على سياسه العلاقات الطيبه مع
الجانب الروسي وهذا الفريق ايضا يزيد من
المشكلات التي يمكن ان تنشا عن تسليح
اوكرانيا بكميات كبيره من الاسلحه لكن في
المقابل ما هو البديل الاوروبي هذا هو
السؤال الذي يجب ان يكرهه اذا لم يتم
تصليح اوكرانيا
وقف الجيش الروسي من التقدم واحتلال
المانيا او تقسيمها كما تريد روسيا بين
بين اقسام تابعه لروسيا واقسامه ممكن ان
تنقرض فيه بولندا والمشرى و البديل هو همم
يعني يجب ان يكون منع روسيا من هذا التقدم
بتسديه اوكرانيا والوقوف ضد العقوبات
الاقتصاديه وجدتنا متاخر لبعض يقول بانه
همم بهذا التسليح ولكن بدون رؤيه موحده
واستراتيجيه لفرض همم وقف هذه الحرب لن
يكون هناك حل حتى بهذه الكميات من التسليح
نتذكر بان هناك محاولات كثيره اجراها
الرئيس الفرنسي مكرون والشورتز ماكرون حصل
على اجابه قبل ايام من الغزو الروسي
لاوكراني بان روسيا لا تنوي مهاجمه
اوكرانيا ولكن في الرابع والعشرين من شهر
فبراير كانت المفاجاه بان روسيا بدات
عمليتها العسكريه قبلها في في ربيعه وخريف
عام 2021 كانت هناك حشود روسيه وروسيا
كانت تاكد بان كل هذه التدريبات هي
تدريبات عاديه
اختصارا شديد دكتور جاسم هل يمكن ان نرى
المانيا خارج هذا التحالف او خارج هذه
المعركه هذه الحرب يوما ما ام هذا
المتابعه تماما
المانيا هي مشاركه وهي عضو تراهن على
حمايه نيته ولديها واجهز كثيره بانت
تهديدات الروسيه فاجد انهم منهم ان تكون
خارج مظله او المظله الامريكيه لكن هي
تريد ان تبقى الحد الادنى على الاقل مع
روسيا سواء كان على مستوى السياسي او
اقتصادي
وضحت الفكره وسيبقى دائما المجال لمتابعه
هذه التطورات شكرا جزيلا لكما من بون همم
الدكتور جاسم محمد رئيس مركز الاوروبي ايه
لدراسه التي مكافحه الارهاب والاستخبارات
من كوبنهاجن سامر ياسر
شكرا لكم